c'est un son distinctif le contact du
bâton avec la balle puis les cris de
joie et d'admiration
lorsque l'étouffante chaleur indienne
s'estompe en fin de journée des milliers
de jeunes jouent au cricket des
bidonvilles au pelage pittoresque avait
lors d'une parade
les écoles sont fermées en raison de la
pandémie mohamed en profite pour passer
encore plus de temps sur ce terrain pour
des milliers de jeunes indiens le
criquet est devenu un refuge pour
échapper aux horreurs de la deuxième
vague qui terrasse le pays activer les
atr la salle à terre
himanshu ne pense qu'à retrouver ses
amis ici chaque jour des instants volés
de pur bonheur
en inde où la foi et les dissensions
religieuses façonnent la vie
on dit que le criquet et la religion
officieuse du pays
les jeunes passionnés les plus fortunés
peuvent pratiquer leur sport favori dans
des centres de formation jovani fait
partie de cette académie de l'eau cno
depuis deux ans il ne vit que pour
s'améliorer il rêve de représenter son
pays sur la scène internationale un jour
son bâton mais comme une épée avec elle
ils se sentent invincibles motivation
ultime un grand nombre de jeunes indiens
rêve de sortir de la pauvreté grâce aux
criquets et plr l'entraîneur vivait n'a
que 22 ans
il espère encore atteindre la
prestigieuse ligue professionnelle
indienne la indian premier league et la
sixième ligue sportive la plus puissante
de la planète après la nfl et les
grandes ligues de soccer en europe
la hype et elle devait offrir une
distraction des moments quotidiens de
répit pendant la pandémie mais les
activités ont été suspendues le 4 mai de
plus en plus d'indiens s'opposait à la
tenue du tournoi olympique de snowboard
la ligue reprendra plus tard dit il
il est plus important de sauver notre
pays et nos citoyens en ce moment
pandémie ou pas le criquet continue de
susciter la ferveur en n é si philippe
leblanc du canada look non